the white house coronavirus task force
is getting ready for a briefing while a
partisan fight plays out on Capitol Hill
the house voting now on a new stimulus
bill that includes much-needed relief
for small businesses
Republicans are pummeling Nancy Pelosi
saying she delayed the process for days
causing unnecessary suffering the GOP
also pending last week's unemployment
claims on the speaker after another four
million Americans lost their jobs take a
look to those 4.4 million Americans that
were laid off this week Congress owes
you an apology
you put everything into your business to
succeed and government told them they
had to shut down for the health of the
nation they made a sacrifice but they
got sacrificed for politics last week
but Pelosi says it's Republicans who
delayed the much-needed money Mitch
McConnell likes to say we delayed the
bill no he delayed the bill and we were
very pleased that he finally came around
to the fact that we had to go forward
with this so he was the one wasting time
all right let's turn maybe this over to
you Jesse yesterday you said that you
are a nonpartisan guy so we'll go to you
for your take as to who is winning on
the politics of this because the
Republicans seem to me to figure out a
way to really try to pin something on
Nancy Pelosi but yet she's blaming them
I don't mind that Nancy squeezed Mitch I
mind that it took her a week to do it I
mean this doesn't take that long but she
dragged this out to steal Trump's
thunder and make all Democrats marvel at
her parliamentary maneuvers I mean if
Nancy Pelosi were a Republican and tried
to posture up like this for a week
during a pandemic the media would hunt
her down like a dog and you'd see all
the lower thirds on cable television
that said policies layoffs but that's
not what happened here's how quickly she
could handle this you ready you get
Mitch on the phone dude dude dude a
cocaine Mitch it's Nancy what we're
gonna do is this I need a little bit
more money for hospitals testing and
small
the slums and we need it done soon Mitch
says hey Nance we can't do this right
now times of the essence could we do it
in a separate bill Nancy says no we do
it now my way or the highway and if you
disagree with me I'll just sleep on it
for a week
Mitch says ok click they call their age
they add language to the draft they call
minuchin says say Treasury we're gonna
need a little bit money for this that
and the other thing and they get it done
in an afternoon but that's not what
Nancy did she dragged it out so she
could have the spotlight so she could
claim credit for getting what she wanted
and gets credit for this economic
recovery it's no surprise to me I mean
she delayed aid to the border she'll
aided the farmers she held up the US MCA
she did this with small business with
unemployed this is what she does and
Republicans are going to complain well
they lost the house in 2018 their voters
didn't show up so you show up in
November you kick her out that's how you
solve problems in Washington Greg who do
you think which side is more persuasive
on this point because that what people
really wanted they just want the money
they want the bangs to be able to
fulfill their loans they don't really
care about the politics of it do the
politics matter at all yeah I don't
think either side is persuasive in this
at all America isn't divided like them
it's just disgusted their lives are
basically hanging in a balance while
these partisan poop-heads and yes I said
poophead at five o'clock sit around in
bicker
they cannot shed themselves of their
partisanship even when people are dying
and people in a lot of these people they
express shock over these job numbers yet
they refuse to say what they believe one
should do about it so they have no skin
in the game they will sit there and
they'll go oh my god and they go walk
into what would you do and then they go
what we need to give more money no you
need to make a decision you need to make
an adult decision so we're watching
essentially a slow-motion disintegration
of a civilization right which means on
the upside we might all
ready almost be there because I think
instinctively we know how far we can go
before poverty anarchy and ultimately
war because that's where it's gonna go
if we don't pull the nose up on this
plane so my optimism is based on how
grim it's getting because that means
we're almost there and we can't go on
like this it sounds like a terrible
relationship but we can't go on like
this it's got to end so here's a
positive way to look at this the bad
news first this is going to happen again
the good news it's gonna happen again
which means we're gonna get through this
one this time and everything we learn is
going to make the next time a piece of
cake we're going to know when to pull
back we're gonna know when the coast
looks clear so what we're going through
now isn't just for now right all this
pain and suffering isn't for now it's
for later this is actually going to pay
off for future generations when another
pandemic comes around so that's a good
way to look at this I just wish that
work because we're American people are
making these sacrifices the politicians
would step up and make their sacrifices
too and stop being a-holes one the
partisans on Capitol Hill are the
members of Congress they're speaking
about each other in in very vitriolic
and almost personal terms in the middle
of this pandemic I mean obviously
tensions are running high but what do
you make of all that I just think it's
bad form Dana I think it's bad form to
play the political blame game when
people are suffering so I think I'm
basically echoing what Jesse and Greg
said I just I think that's regrettable
and I think which is what you really
need here is to focus on what is
necessary to help the American people
and get them effective helps so when
people talk about delay I don't think
it's any delay to craft legislation
that's effective in terms of delivering
necessary help to people who are
suffering through a health emergency and
economic emergency and what we saw last
time by the way is that Republicans and
Democrats signed on to a bill that
didn't get the job done didn't stop the
job losses for
example and instead what we're reading
in the papers is that the big banks were
rewarding the wealthy clients and small
business didn't get the aid that they
needed and today you hear you know
Senate Majority Leader McConnell saying
oh yeah well let the states go bankrupt
again forget the policy that's a
different would you say such a thing but
one that's a different point the
bankruptcies obstructive I totally
different it's an idea what you got to
say it's just okay let's just set the
record straight
I mean there was a clean there was a
clean bill that once they found out that
the the small business pot was going to
be dry there was a clean bill to put
more money in it Nancy Pelosi did not go
forward with that period the end stop
there so yes they wanted to do other
things Democrats did but to have an
answer that says that it was Mitch
McConnell who delayed is really
political jujitsu and you have to have
somebody that pushes back and says wait
a second in that time that there was a
delay there are X number of small
businesses around the country that had
to make the decision I haven't gotten
the money so I've got to let these
people go so when the number goes up
four point four million on unemployment
there's a reason that it goes up that
way and that delay is part of it well
I'm being told we have a little extra
time here so we have the McConnell saw
at this point that Juan brought up about
the states and what senator Mitch
McConnell said about funding for the
states and helping them out and Cuomo's
responses play that we'll get reaction
on the other side I would certainly be
in favor of allowing states to use the
bankruptcy route it's saved some cities
my guess is their first choice would be
for the federal government to borrow
money from future generations to send it
down to them now so they don't have to
do that that's not something I'm going
to be in favor of
New York puts in more money to the
federal pot than it takes out his state
takes out more than it puts it
Senator McConnell who's getting bailed
out here
it's your state that is living on the
money that we generate Greg let me turn
it over to you so there was just a
budget that was passed in New York State
I don't think there was a single budget
cut in it and this is before coronavirus
but this is a this is going to be a huge
issue because there are a lot of states
that were not in good financial shape
even before the coronavirus so what
happens next
yeah and it seems to me before there
were viruses there were cities run by
Democrats that were declaring bankruptcy
without the help of a pandemic they were
just declaring bankruptcy or they were
broke just by spending so I don't buy it
I'm I this is just this whole segment
just angers me because we're getting
we're just falling back into the same
mistakes that we make every time but
this time is different
because these mistakes can cost you the
civilization and this isn't like we're
not like arguing over you know a
government shutdown we're not arguing
over whether we you know closed down
some of the parks because we're having a
sequestration this isn't even an
impeachment discussion this is where our
leaders cannot even make an adult
decision which actually could ruin
everybody's lives we could all be
destroyed that's why I have to stop
every time I'm about to say something
because it's gonna use 16 different
words that begin with the letter F I
think we should just leave it right
there because that was a good way to end
it F word and all